Okay,
let's,
uh,
let's start,
let's see.
We started talking about black holes last time and there's now going to be a
problem set that is going to be available later today,
uh,
due next week.
Uh,
and I should also point out that,
uh,
I've put together this website on black holes,
actually some of the help sheets already,
uh,
sent you to that,
to that website.
Uh,
and I'll put a link on the classes server as a whole,
but,
but here it is,
uh,
as an actual URL,
www.cmigotyale.edu/b h for black holes.
And that website kind of serves as a sort of online textbook for this part of
the course.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
so you have something,
something written down to look at for this whole section of the course.
And as you'll see,
many of the things we'll be talking about are actually,
uh,
discussed on that website as well,
so you can find out more information there.
Uh,
okay.
so I,
last time I defined a black hole.
This is simply something,
uh,
simply something where the escape velocity is faster than the speed of light or
alternatively,
and this is a match to the exact same thing,
the radius of the object is less than the Schwab trilled radius,
which is defined for an object of any given mass.
Uh,
and this isn't particularly extraordinary or interesting,
uh,
as long as the speed of light isn't particularly extraordinary or interesting.
And one of the things that happens when you start talking about relativity is
that it turns out the speed of light is a very important quantity.
So,
uh,
this,
these are interesting
because the speed of light is an interesting
okay.
And,
uh,
we'll talk in a minute about how all this arises.
But one of the interesting things about the speed of light is that you can't go
any faster.
It's the,
it's the speed limit and uh,
no physical process can make you go faster than the speed of light.
So C is fastest a velocity possible.
And the consequence of that is supposing you have one of these black hole thing.
So here's some object and it's got some radius.
Uh,
and its radius and its mass are such that the escape velocity here is greater
than the speed of life.
Uh,
you can imagine that around it is a kind of imaginary sphere.
Let's put it in
and dot.
And this is the,
a sphere where the escape velocity is equal to the speed of light.
Uh,
and you remember what the formula for the escape Velocity v escape is equal to
two.
Gene m over,
uh,
are the square root of,
of,
uh,
to GM over r.
And so if,
uh,
if on the surface of this object,
the escape velocity is greater than life than that of light,
if you keep moving out are we'll keep getting bigger.
And so eventually you'll come to a point in space,
uh,
where the escape velocity is equal to the speed of light.
And,
uh,
this is called a,
the event horizon.
And the reason it's called that is because if nothing can go faster than the
speed of light,
what it means is that any event that takes place inside this imaginary sphere,
uh,
can't radiate any information about what's going on to the outside.
Because,
uh,
this,
the escape velocity is greater than the speed of light.
Light can't escape.
And because nothing else can go faster than the speed of light,
nothing else can escape.
And so no information of any kind,
uh,
can come,
comes from inside the event horizon to the outside.
Okay.
And so in a certain philosophical sense,
uh,
this event horizon sort of constitutes an edge of the universe because nothing
that happens inside can affect what happens outside in any way you can't see in,
you can't detect anything that goes on inside,
no event inside this event horizon,
uh,
can,
tell us,
uh,
about itself or a,
and we,
there's no in principle,
no way we can find out anything about what happens inside an event horizon.
Uh,
it turns out that this rather grandiose statement that the event horizon
constitutes an edge of the universe has a mathematical meaning as well.
The great physicist,
Stephen Hawking,
you may have heard about him.
He's the guy in the wheelchair.
Uh,
his,
uh,
shorthand,
his,
uh,
one of his great discoveries was to demonstrate that the mathematics of the
event horizon is actually very similar to the mathematics of another edge of the
universe,
namely the Big Bang,
which is the start of the universe in time.
And so it turns out that this statement that this constitutes an edge of the
universe is not just a philosophical statement having to do with defining the
universe as something we might eventually,
possibly know something about or be influenced by,
but also has a mathematical meaning as well.
And so the way you have to think about the universe is as a kind of Swiss cheese
are holes in it,
there are holes in it which aren't part,
uh,
of,
of our universe where these little event horizons cut,
uh,
cut pieces out.
And,
uh,
it's this kind of thing that gives black holes the kind of extraordinary aura of
mystery that they sort of have in,
uh,
in everyday life.
Uh,
various strange things happen inside the event horizon.
And now I better pause cause I just contradicted myself,
right.
Because I said a minute ago that you can't find out anything about what happens
in the event horizon.
And now I'm about to tell you what happens inside an event horizon.
Okay?
So,
uh,
it were a 10 or eight minutes into class and already,
I'm,
I'm contradicting myself.
And so let me explain exactly what I mean by this.
Here's what you do.
If you want to make statements about what's going on,
on the inside of a,
of one of these things,
what you do is you take the equations that apply outside the event horizon.
You assume that the same equations are going to apply inside the event horizon.
Turns out the mathematics of these things.
And I'll show you an example of this next week.
Uh,
the mathematics of these things do very bizarre things at the event horizon.
But,
uh,
mathematicians are smart people.
One can cope with these kinds of problems.
At tents,
you tend to have problems like everything gets divided by zero,
right at the event horizon.
Uh,
but as you may recall,
if you've done a good pre calculus course,
there are ways you can get past those kinds of infinities.
Uh,
but everything goes haywire.
A,
but if you make the assumption that the same set of equations apply inside the
event horizon as outside,
you can then manipulate those equations,
interpret the results as if the symbols mean the same thing inside as they do
outside.
And then make statements about what happens inside the event horizon.
And this looks a lot like physics,
right?
Because you've got a bunch of equations and you know,
some of them Stanford time and some of them stand for space and the energy and
all this good stuff.
And,
uh,
you can do manipulations of those equations and then you can make statements
about what happens.
Uh,
but it looks like physics.
You can make an argument that it isn't actually physics because you're making an
assumption that those equations apply inside there.
And that's an assumption that is untestable not even in principle untestable
because,
uh,
you can't ever get any information about what's going on in there to see if
those really are the right equations.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
here's something where it looks like physics,
but depending on what you define the limits of physics to be,
and this is kind of a deep philosophical question that we won't go too far into.
Uh,
it might actually be something that while interesting is really something else.
So,
uh,
just a couple of examples of the kinds of things,
that you can deduce from the mathematics about what goes on inside a event.
Horizons one,
here's something,
um,
all matter,
uh,
with are less than the swatch showed radius.
Oh,
this distance here will always be the Schwartz Shield radius by definition,
because that's the radius away from an object where the escape velocity is equal
to the speed of light.
So all matter inside the truck showed radius collapses
to a single point,
uh,
in a finite amount of time.
So it doesn't take forever to do this.
Okay.
And that point,
since it's got a lot of matter,
but no volume,
that's what a point is.
That's a point of infinite density,
okay?
Uh,
and this is sometimes called the singularity
and you could see some of the problems with doing mathematics inside,
uh,
inside event horizons.
If you're trying to calculate the density for this density is mass over volume.
If you've got a bunch of,
of mass in a single point,
the volume is zero and you've just divided by zero and you're in all kinds of
trouble.
Um,
so,
uh,
it,
everything collapses down to a,
a point of infinite density.
There's no force strong enough to stop this from happening.
You can't set up a rocket system to keep yourself in or burger.
Keep yourself from falling down.
Uh,
partly that one way of understanding that is that the energy you would exert in,
tried to hold yourself up has a mass equivalent.
You'll recall that e equals MC squared.
So for a given amount of energy,
there's a mass equivalent.
The extra mass just pulls you down more.
Uh,
so you can't bike stent expanding energy.
You can't hold yourself up,
uh,
inside a singularity.
So everything collapses.
It's also true.
This is a,
the kind of thing you see in popular accounts of black holes.
Uh,
the statement is sometimes made the properties of space and time are reversed.
That's a weird thing to say.
Uh,
what could this possibly mean?
well,
let's see.
Uh,
it's related actually to what,
uh,
what I just said that everything falls down to a singularity in ordinary,
in an ordinary situation,
uh,
we can move around in space.
I can expand energy and move all around,
uh,
in space.
I can move back and forth.
That could jump up and down.
See,
uh,
but you don't have a lot of choice of where you go in time.
Uh,
you move forward in time at the rate of one day per day,
right?
Uh,
and you can expand a lot of energy trying to avoid that.
and it won't actually do you any good.
So inside an event horizon,
you fall down to a singularity.
And as I said,
you could expand a lot of energy,
but it doesn't change your trajectory in space.
So what happens when you,
when you fire off your rocket,
uh,
well in principle,
providing you believe in all of these equations,
you could in principle move around in time.
Uh,
and this is why the science fiction writers like black holes so much because
it's a kind of scientifically certified time machine.
You're going to the event horizon,
you turn on your energy packed and move all around in time.
And then what they forget to tell you is that you're inside an event horizon.
So it does you no good because you can't come out again.
Uh,
and so then,
uh,
the effort is to try and figure out a way that you could have this nice effect
of,
of the time machine without having an event horizon.
And,
uh,
in particular there's some interest in whether one can have what's been
described as a naked singularity,
a naked singularity as a singularity with no event horizon around it so that you
could get in down to where all the weird physics happens and then come back out
again.
Uh,
caulking proposed what he called the cosmic censorship theorem.
that is the statement that naked singularities are not allowed.
Uh,
and uh,
so hence Santra ship,
uh,
can't have naked singularities.
And there is,
uh,
to this day some dispute over whether that will turn out to be true in general
or not.
Um,
and you can go on in this vein,
you can talk,
uh,
you can talk on and on about the,
the extraordinary physical,
uh,
events and properties that these things might actually have a,
and what you have to keep in mind as you're doing this is that there's a limit
to,
uh,
how much this could ever even in principle be realized in real life.
You know,
you fall into one of these wormholes that they like to have on the science
fiction,
uh,
in the science fiction stories.
Uh,
and you better have some fairy tricky physics if you're going to be able to come
back out again.
Uh,
and that's not something that the science fiction world typically dwells on,
although it is interesting.
Uh,
you know,
you know the movie contact.
So this is a US based on Carl Sagan is novel of the same name.
And one of the things that happens late in this is,
uh,
this was the first use I think in science fiction of the concept of a warm hall
where you fall into a,
a,
a black hole and you fall out again somewhere totally different in space and
time.
And there's an interesting story about this,
that what happened is supposedly was that Sagan,
when he was writing his novel,
got to the point in the novel and he needed something to happen for plot
reasons,
uh,
in order to,
move the plot forward.
And He,
uh,
he saved himself was,
was not an expert in relativity.
So he called up one of his friends who was a guy named Kip Thorne,
one of the most famous general relativity people.
He said,
look,
here's what has to happen in my novel.
Give me some science jargon so that,
that make this work.
And Thorn,
who was very smart guy thought about this for a while,
came up with this concept of the Wormhole,
uh,
that,
you know,
you fall into a black hole here and you fall out of it again on the other side.
Then thorn went away and thought about this for awhile.
At least this is what he claims in his book and said,
you know,
this might work.
Uh,
and a whole series of scientific papers flowed from that.
So here is a place where art pushed science art in the form of science fiction.
If you consider that art,
uh,
pushes science pushes science forward rather than the other way round,
quite unusual,
uh,
in that case.
All right.
Um,
so all of this is great,
but I want to focus a little bit on,
uh,
what does it actually mean?
These grand statements that what makes about you can't go faster than the speed
of light space and time are reversed and so forth.
Uh,
what actually underlies those statements and to what extent are these sort of
spectacular kinds of phenomena,
actually a realized in the real world.
So I'm an observational astronomer.
Uh,
what right?
Do I even have to talk about black holes?
The number one characteristic of which is that you can't see them at all.
Uh,
so,
uh,
that's where we're going to go in a minute.
And to do that,
we have to talk about a relativity special relativity and general relativity,
uh,
because those are the theories that underlie all of this.
So,
uh,
before we go plunging into that,
let me,
uh,
pause for questions at this point.
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
Yes,
you should be,
uh,
yeah.
So the quote a little confused about why space and time are reversed.
Uh,
let me not answer that now because there's,
there's math next week which will make that a little bit clearer.
I think it is a legitimate question,
not just to ask,
uh,
why are space and time reverse?
But what that even could mean.
Uh,
and,
and we'll get back to that in a little while.
Yes,
go ahead.
Singularity.
It doesn't stay in den Steven Neutral,
right?
And doesn't do,
so supposing you have,
for example,
a neutron star that's a little bit smaller than it's,
uh,
then it's event horizon.
Why wouldn't it just stay there inside it to vent horizon rather than collapsing
down?
Uh,
and again,
this is a calculation that I don't think I can demonstrate for you,
but it,
it comes about because the,
the energy,
the pressure forces that would have to hold it up actually also contribute to
the mass of the thing.
And if you then compute the,
uh,
the balance,
the hydrostatic equilibrium that we were talking about last time,
it never works.
It can't work because the amount energy required to hold it up is so great that
the mass equivalent is going to generate a additional gravitational forces.
And if this were a different kind of course,
I do the calculation,
but,
but let's not go there.
Uh,
yes.
Yeah,
I would say no,
no,
that's fine.
Yeah.
Well,
the thing is,
uh,
in,
in our normal situation,
we have no choice about where we go in time and the statement that I made,
which I didn't back up in any way to,
uh,
that a rational person would really want to believe me.
But let me make this statement again.
Inside the event horizon,
uh,
you can,
you can move around in time.
You don't necessarily have to go have to go forward.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that is the thing that is the piece of the picture that the science fiction
writers tend to tend to hone in on.
Um,
and so,
uh,
you know,
the statement is made about John,
about relativity and I'll,
and I'll make this explicit and then a little while,
uh,
time is the fourth dimension.
Uh,
you know,
there are three space dimensions,
one time dimension,
a new a,
and you can do all sorts of calculations that way,
but it's perfectly clear just from everyday life that the time dimension is not
the same as the space dimensions because we don't have the opportunity to move
around it.
So it must be true then are in a certain sense time.
Uh,
the time dimension,
if you want to call it that,
of the space time continuum,
uh,
must somehow behave differently from the spatial components.
And they do.
And I'll show you why in a little while.
Uh,
and that behavior,
uh,
is reversed between space and time inside,
inside the event horizon.
Things that are positive terms in the equation become negative and vice versa.
And as I say,
we'll actually,
I'll actually write some of this down.
Yeah.
Since you can escape it,
the black hole is one of the possible scenarios for the end of the university,
like at all matter of being in the form of law.
Okay.
So since nothing can escape from,
uh,
from a black hole,
is that a possible end of the universe?
Yes.
Uh,
one of the potential ways the universe could evolve,
the universe is expanding right now.
Again,
this is now in the third part of the course.
We'll talk about this.
The universe is expanding,
but it's got a lot of matter in it.
So in principle it could stop expanding and collapsing.
Uh,
you could ask the question,
does the universe expand faster than its own escape velocity or not?
And this is a question that can not only be asked but answer,
it could expand slow down,
stop,
fall,
back together again.
And if that happens at a certain point when it fell together,
the whole universe would be incited to vent horizon.
Now how that would affect those of us who are inside a is a,
is a little less clear.
Eventually you'd get crushed.
Right.
But,
uh,
because nothing would be able to stop the,
inexorable collapse down to a singularity.
Yeah.
At that point.
But yeah,
that is a potential end of the universe is we all end up inside a big event
horizon.
We all collapse down to a singularity in the middle.
Uh,
it turns out that isn't what's going to happen,
at least not from current observations.
The current observations is that the universe is expanding faster than its own
escape velocity.
So you have the opposite Andy Point where it just keeps getting bigger and
bigger and more and more diffuse and sparse and cold and boring.
Uh,
and the universe ends that way.
But again,
that's part three of the course.
We'll get there.
Yes.
Where does all the Masco when it collapses,
the mass is still there.
The mass is still there.
And this is actually a very important,
important point because,
uh,
things can still be in orbit around a black hole and not fall in.
Because when you're far enough away,
when you're outside the event horizon,
it just behaves like any other mass.
Black holes can move through space.
They can orbit around other things.
Things can orbit around then if the sun turned into a black hole right now,
uh,
well we would freeze.
But,
uh,
aside from that,
the orbit of the earth,
if the sun turned into a black hole of the same mass as the earth,
uh,
the orbit of the Earth wouldn't change because we're far enough away that it
just seems like any other mass down there.
So a solar mass black hole could have a planet in exactly the same more,
but as the earth is around the sun,
this is one of the differences between how black holes actually behave and the
metaphorical use of black holes.
But,
uh,
you know,
this is one of those words that gets used in common culture for various things
and it usually carries a connotation of a kind of great sucking thing that pulls
everything in a inexorably.
That's true inside the event horizon,
which is where this idea arises from.
But if you're outside the event horizon,
you could just keep going around in circles around it and exactly the same way
that you can be in orbit around any other kinds of mass.
Why is there no volume?
Ah,
okay.
So why is there no volume?
Uh,
w with this stuff at this center,
if there's nothing to think and think about what we were talking about,
hydrostatic equilibrium the other day,
if there's nothing to stop the collapse every,
if there's no energy or pressure force sufficient to stop the collapse,
everything has to end up in the same place.
It all falls to the center and you can calculate how long that will take.
And after that happens,
all the mass is down at the center.
Uh,
and what does it mean to be the center?
It's the central point.
Now,
in fact,
there's gotta be this,
this is how it works in relativity.
Relativity does not incorporate quantum mechanics.
Quantum mechanics does funny things when things get small.
And so it is likely that there are physical effects that we don't understand at
the quantum level before you get to precisely the same point.
But we don't know what they are because that would require a theory that
encompasses special,
a general relativity and quantum mechanics at the same time.
And until the strength he has finished their work,
we don't have such a theory.
Uh,
so probably something happens to prevent a pure point,
but we don't know what it is.
And so from the point of view on the outside,
you just imagine everything falling down toward his central point and kind of
landing there in some way.
But it is a mystery.
Uh,
yes.
Okay.
Uh,
the unit is the universe finite.
Yes.
Uh,
it's got it.
In fact,
you know,
it has to be finite because the sky is dark at night.
Uh,
let me explain that.
If the universe were infinite and had stars distributed at random throughout the
universe,
then any direction you looked at,
you'd eventually,
uh,
see the surface of a star.
You could do this in a calculus kind of way by integrating over the total light
of the universe.
Uh,
and so it can't be infinite in extent and filled with stars the same,
uh,
as,
as stars like the sun or,
or any kind of star really that is distributed evenly.
So one of several things must be the case,
either the universities in homogeneous.
That is to say we live in a very special place where there are stars after a
while,
there are no stars anymore or it has to be finite in extent.
It only goes out a certain distance and stops or it has to be finite in time.
That is to say it began a certain number of years ago and a and didn't exist
before that that helps you because then you only if it's,
if the universe is 13 billion years old,
you only see things that are within 13 billion light years because the light
hasn't had a chance to travel.
Uh,
it turns out that it's pro,
uh,
the easiest way to understand this is it's the ladder.
Uh,
the universe had a beginning and this is the whole idea of the big bang that it
started as some kind of very small object and then expanded at some finite and
indeed calculable time ago.
The Universe is now thought to be,
I think it's 13.7 plus or minus point 4 billion years old.
Uh,
and so the finiteness of the universe at the moment is,
uh,
the primary reason it's finite is that it's finite in time.
Not so much that it's finite in space,
but it has to be,
it has to be limited in some way or you'd see an infinite amount of starlight.
Okay.
Excellent.
With the universe is finite.
What's outside the universe?
That is exactly the right question.
Uh,
I can't answer that because,
uh,
although I will try and section three of the course,
we'll,
we'll learn much more about this stuff.
I can't answer that because you know,
what is the universe?
The Universe is what we can study scientifically.
And,
uh,
so the very first question that is sets up a person has about,
you know,
the Big Bang of the finite universe is what's outside it.
And that's actually not a science question because it intrinsically unanswerable
by scientific means.
Now there are things you can say about it just as you could.
There are things you can say about the inside of an event horizon and you can
base them on scientific ideas and scientific thinking.
And you can say these nice things about space and time and one can say similar
things about,
uh,
what's outside the universe and,
you know,
how it might've come to be and so forth.
But you've done a little epistemological shift when you start talking about
those kinds of things cause you're no longer talking about things that even in
principle can be verified by observation or experiment.
Uh,
so I do have some things to say about that.
I'll say it in the third part of the course when we talk about the universe.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you should think about what I have to say about that in a different way.
From what you,
from what you think about what I have to say about how planets orbit around the
Sun.
Uh,
we'll,
we'll come back to this later.
Yes,
go ahead.
How did they,
how do they find that?
That's the next three weeks of the course,
that person and in fact,
that is the subject of my research.
Uh,
this is what I do for a living.
I find black holes and I'll tell you how,
I'll tell you how it's done.
We can,
we can see if we can find another one over the next few weeks or so.
Yes,
no.
Ah,
is it possible that we are inside an event horizon and we don't know it?
Uh,
yes.
In that,
um,
uh,
again,
this relates to the question that was asked over here.
Could it be that the universe is going to ultimately collapse and be inside a
black hole supposing that happen?
Supposing,
uh,
we were in the collapsing phase of universe gradually over many billions of
years falling down to some singularity.
We would not necessarily know that.
Now if you approach a black hole that is of the size of a star or even the size
of a galaxy,
uh,
when you got close,
you'd feel it.
And the way you'd feel it is if you're falling in your feet would be closer to
the center,
then your,
then your head and the gravitational force on your feet would be SIF stronger
than that on your head and you'd stretch.
Uh,
and so if we were really near to a black hole of a size,
uh,
of objects,
we understand,
then we'd know that because the tidal forces on our bodies would,
uh,
would mean that we couldn't keep ourselves together.
But you can imagine a sufficiently big black hole kind of encompassing the whole
universe that wouldn't affect us in that way.
Uh,
so it's not inconceivable.
Yeah.
First implies like two direction.
Oh
yeah.
So the,
the word reverse in this reverse space and time.
Uh,
how about this?
I agree that,
that,
that wording might not be,
I've seen this wording used,
which is why I used it,
but I,
I agree that it might not be the best wording one could use.
How about the properties of space and the properties of time are interchanged
with each other.
That's a den.
It doesn't have this kind of directional thing.
It's about how these,
uh,
how these things behave.
Yeah.
Is the earth get me?
He's from other stars?
Yes.
Well,
of course we do a,
if you look out in the sun in the sky,
you see starch when we see the radiation from those stars.
And so of course there's a radiation in all forms.
He and otherwise,
the fraction of the radiation that we get from sources other than the sun is
extremely small.
The vegetable at all,
like at night.
Would it be cold?
No.
No,
because,
uh,
and,
and here's why.
Because the second most prominent source of heat that we have is actually
geothermal heat from the center of the earth.
And that's vastly more than the sum of all contributions by stars.
And it's vastly less than what we get from the,
from our own son.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
radioactivity and the,
and the latent heat and the core of the earth.
That's,
that's by far more than anything that comes to us from the start.
But we certainly do get energy radiation from the stars if we didn't,
astronomers would be out of business.
Cause this is how we,
uh,
this is how we study them by looking at the radiation.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let's,
let's say that you're inside the event horizon a black hole.
And,
um,
as I remembered,
this circular velocity of any object is less than the escape velocity.
So couldn't you theoretically orbit the black hole inside the event horizon?
Excellent question.
Could you orbit it?
Could you get yourself into a stable orbit,
uh,
inside,
an event horizon?
If everything were in work?
The way Newtonian mechanics says it works,
you could,
uh,
but it turns out they're relativistic.
Correction.
There is something called the smallest circular,
smallest state inner most circular stable orbit.
I C A.
most stable circular orbit.
That's important,
uh,
because that actually can be observed in various ways.
And we'll talk about this in two weeks time.
Uh,
the inner most staple circular orbit turns out to be outside the event horizon.
but you're right,
if you were only using Newtonian calculations,
there would be that square root of two when you could imagine being in a
circular orbit inside the event horizon.
But that's one of the things that,
uh,
is different about the relativistic calculation.
It turns out that for non rotating black holes,
the inner most stable circular orbit is three times the,
uh,
Schwab chilled radius.
Yes.
It seems like there'd be a very real possibility.
Ah,
yes.
Uh,
so is there a potential for a black hole to accumulate an infinite amount of
mass,
which is the sort of vacuum cleaners scenario?
Um,
first of all,
there isn't an infinite amount of mass in the universe necessarily.
Universities,
finite,
uh,
second of all,
even if there was,
if there was a huge black hole here and something else outside the event horizon
that's moving faster than the escape velocity of this thing,
at that point,
then it doesn't fall in.
So it's not necessarily true that it will pile up an infinite amount of mass.
In fact,
black holes,
typic black holes ought not to have infinite mass.
They ought to have a particular amount of mass.
They'll gain more,
uh,
as stuff falls in.
But if stuff doesn't fall in,
if it's moving faster than the escape velocity,
then they won't accumulate it.
You haven't observed?
Well,
it depends what you have.
We observed extremely massive black holes.
It depends what you mean by extremely massive.
The massive,
most massive black holes that we know anything about,
or about 3 billion times the mass of the sun.
Uh,
so that's pretty massive,
but it's about the same as an ordinary galaxy.
Uh,
and we,
what we don't have evidence for is,
uh,
black holes that are substantially more massive than a whole galaxies of stars.
We don't,
there's no evidence for that.
So they're basically,
just to jump ahead,
there are basically two kinds of black holes that we have empirical evidence
for.
One are black holes,
the uh,
about 10 times the mass of the sun,
so masses of individual stars.
And then there are the so called supermassive black holes,
which are the masters of whole galaxies.
And those are the kinds of black holes for which we have direct evidence at the
moment.
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
So is it possible to detect the presence of a black hole by looking at things
around it?
Yes,
that's exactly what is done.
And we'll just,
I'll describe this in the next couple of weeks.
Uh,
but it doesn't happen the way you suggest.
It's not like something suddenly disappears.
So we know it fell into the event horizon.
What you do is you see these things in stable orbits around that are perfectly
happy going around in circles around the black hole.
Uh,
for example,
you can see binary stars,
double stars in which there's a black hole in something else and these things
are in nice stable orbits.
And you infer the properties of one object by looking at the motion of the other
object.
That's exactly what we did for the planets.
Uh,
and so you can do that again for blocks
disappeared,
uh,
if,
if you actually saw something disappearing.
Um,
yeah.
Uh,
and in fact there is,
uh,
there is indirect evidence that there's material falling through that in some
systems there is material currently falling through,
uh,
the horizon of black holes.
And in fact,
that's one of the things that is a,
a current topic of active research is can you demonstrate that,
uh,
if there were a black hole in our own solar system anywhere near us,
we'd know it.
Uh,
and the reason we'd know it is that's a lot of mass.
It would disrupt the orbits of the planet.
And as long as the planets are,
and so we have a kind of early warning system,
but for black hole cruises by Pluto's orbit gets disturbed first.
And so all of those nice objects out there in the Kuiper belt,
uh,
their orbits would go all haywire if something as ma as massive as a stellar
mass black hole were accidentally to come,
uh,
come nearby in exactly the same way there would be as if an ordinary star of the
same mass where to,
where to come by.
You wouldn't be able to see it,
but the orbits of everything would be changed rather drastically.
So,
uh,
the odds of us actually falling into a black hole are extremely small.
And if it were to happen,
we'd get of great deal of advanced notice.
So,
and not to worry,
uh,
there are astronomical things you may be,
should worry about asteroids crashing into the earth.
This isn't one of them.
Actually.
Uh,
Bethany Cobb and I were on a TV show that explored this particular possibility.
This was a wonderful thing happened last summer,
uh,
where ABC news decided to have a two hour special on all the different ways the
earth could be destroyed.
And they called us up and we went out to New York.
It was very entertaining and tie.
And I,
I,
you know,
but I was too much of a scientist.
I kept saying,
it isn't going to happen.
You shouldn't worry about it.
You know,
you should worry about the asteroids and global warming and all this kind of
stuff.
Don't be worrying about black holes coming,
rolling in.
And of course,
the consequence of that is that I didn't get a lot of screen time,
uh,
and the,
and the guys from the American Museum of natural history who are better at
popularizing science than I am,
uh,
got all the screen time.
So,
you know,
I know better now.
We'll,
we'll,
uh,
we'll speak in better sound bites next time round.
Uh,
yeah,
that was fun.
Uh,
we should screen it,
or at least the first part,
other questions all will become clear in due time.
Actually that's not true,
but some things will become clear in realtime.
Gosh,
this was great.
Excellent.
All sorts of questions.
Um,
so now,
uh,
let me at least start,
talking about special relativity.
Uh,
there are two kinds of relativity.
There's special relativity and special relativity,
which was devised in,
uh,
in 1905 by,
by Einstein.
This is essentially a set of laws of motion.
So it's the same thing as Newton's laws of motion only.
It's a more elaborate version of it.
So it's substitutes,
if you will,
for Newton's laws of motion and in fact incorporates Newton's laws of motion.
Then there's general relativity,
uh,
discovered about 10 years later again by Einstein.
Uh,
and this is the equivalent of a law of gravity.
You'll remember that the way,
yeah.
Uh,
one has to calculate orbits in the Newtonian theory is you take Newton's law of
gravity and you plug it into Newton's laws of motion.
Uh,
so this is a change or an enhancement in the laws of motion.
This is a change or an enhancement in the law of gravity in both of these cases,
and this is important to,
to realize it doesn't overturn what Newton did.
This is a misconception about how scientific revolutions work.
This is as revolutionary a set of ideas as you could possibly imagine.
And yet Newton's laws are still still whole.
They don't overturn them.
What they do is they say Newton's laws are not general laws,
but laws that only operate in certain specific situations.
These are thou the general laws that operate always and new moons.
Uh,
calculations are a subset of these things that only work under certain
conditions.
Uh,
and uh,
just to jump ahead a little bit,
the condition is there's a,
there's a,
a quantity.
Uh,
so now I'm going to talk first about special relativity.
we'll leave gravity to later.
Uh,
but now let's just talk about how things move.
And this is important because this gives rise to the limit on,
uh,
to the limit on,
on velocity.
All velocities must be left less than or equal to the speed of light.
You can't go faster than the speed of light.
Uh,
and just to jump ahead,
the way Newton's laws of motion relate to special relativity is through a
parameter,
a quantity called gamma.
And this is equal to this quantity one minus v squared,
oversee squared,
square root of that in the denominator,
okay,
one over the square root of one minus p squared overseas squared.
And when v is much,
much less than the speed of light,
then gamma is equal to one.
You can see if this v as much less than the speed of light.
This quantity is more or less zero.
You got one divided by one GAM as equal to one.
Newtonian physics assumes that gamma is equal to one.
So this leads directly to all of Newtonian physics
as velocity start to get higher.
Gamma starts to be different from what and if as v approaches the speed of
light,
what's going to happen?
This is going to,
if he is the speed of Light v squared,
oversee squared is one.
You've got one minus one in the denominator.
So you've got zero in the denominator.
So as v approaches,
the speed of light gamma approaches infinity.
Okay.
And then you get,
so you start to get these relativistic effects.
MMM.
So it turns out,
for example,
in relativistic,
uh,
in relativistic physics that mass isn't exactly what Newton thought mass was.
Mass is,
uh,
what's called the rest mass.
This is the Newtonian bass
times gamma.
So if everything's moving slowly and uh,
gamma is equal to one,
then the mass is exactly what Newton thought it was going to be.
A,
it's a,
it's a property of objects.
It's constant.
It doesn't change.
Mass is conserved and you can do all the wonderful calculations that you can do
in Newtonian,
uh,
in Newtonian gravity.
Now the properties of gamma,
our sex,
remember this goes to infinity,
that therefore as the velocity goes to the speed of light,
the mass approaches infinity because gamma and approaches infinity and you're
multiplying the Newtonian mass by some number that's getting larger and larger
and larger and larger as you get a closer to,
uh,
as you get closer to the speed of light.
Now what does this mean?
Remember Newton's laws of motion.
Let's go all the way back to Newton.
This is a force is equal to mass times acceleration.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Go ahead.
Gamma is a,
is a parameter that tells you how relativistic you are.
It is defined by
this.
So it's,
it's,
it's a function of your velocity.
Yeah.
And weather and,
and how diff,
how much bigger than what it is tells you how far away from the Newtonian theory
relativity is.
And the faster you go,
the closer you get to,
to the speed of light,
uh,
the,
the more relativistic you become and the less Tony and you are.
So it's a parameter that tells you how,
how close you are to Newton.
Other questions?
Yes.
How was gamma derived it?
I'll talk about the history of this next time.
Uh,
but basically,
uh,
it was Einstein revise the laws of motion in response to some experiments which
weren't giving the right Newtonian answer.
That's the short version of the we'll do the long version next time.
And it was the genius of Einstein that he recognized,
uh,
how it,
how the laws of motion should be modified NDD debt.
They should be modified at all,
which was not most other people's initial reaction to these experiments.
Okay.
So now,
uh,
what happens if you're mass becomes infinite,
right?
That meets four,
eight that remember,
this is acceleration and this is force.
If you're mass becomes infinite,
then f over m which is equal to the acceleration goes to zero,
which means you cannot have any acceleration,
no matter how much force you apply.
And that's why you can't go faster than the speed of light,
right?
Because as you get closer and closer to the speed of light,
this gamma factor becomes larger and larger that makes your mass larger and
larger.
And then to get a given amount of acceleration,
since this is huge,
you have to have an increasing amount of force.
By the time you get to the speed of light.
Uh,
the mass is,
uh,
sorry it,
it's this whole thing that's zero,
not the mass.
Uh,
by the time you get to the speed of light,
uh,
you need an infinite amount of force to accelerate yourself.
So you need an infinite amount of force in order to go faster.
And so,
uh,
by the time you get out to the speed of light,
you can't go faster because it would take an infinite amount of force to do so.
Yes,
yes.
Does that mean that when you were traveling at the speed of light,
and not only can you not speed up,
but you also can't slow down take for us to slow you down.
Uh,
that's right.
And what it really means though is that nothing with a non zero mass can
actually ever get to the speed of light.
Uh,
and therefore what about like,
uh,
light has zero mass.
It has to,
otherwise it can't go at the speed of light.
So,
uh,
if m zero is zero,
then this whole thing applies in a very different way.
Uh,
and so anything that goes at the speed of light has to be massless for just this
kind of reason.
Yeah.
Energy.
Then
it has a mass equivalent,
but it's rest mass is zero.
So the reason it has energy is because you've got zero times infinity.
And so if you slow light down,
then it disappears all together,
right?
Because,
uh,
if you saw a light in a vacuum down,
I should specify it disappears all together.
Because if this isn't infinite and this is zero,
then you've got no mass energy at all.
Yes.
You can't accelerate or decelerate.
How'd you get sort of intrinsic velocity?
Well,
uh,
what is an intrinsic philosophy?
This is where relativity becomes relative.
It depends on how fast the person who's observing you is going.
Uh,
but,
uh,
remember this only applies if you're already moving at the speed of light.
If you're not moving at the speed of light,
then this isn't infinite.
You have some finite mass and you can change your velocity.
Remember,
acceleration is a change in velocity,
uh,
by applying force.
And as long as the mass isn't infinite,
it just,
you know,
you can calculate how much force it takes and that's how much it takes to change
your velocity.
Other questions?
Excellent questions.
Uh,
all around.
This is not at all straightforward.
Uh,
and we will continue next time.